do you need a new key for your dodge or
for a chrysler jeep or some volkswagen
vehicles well i've got a solution for
you i'm mike with tomahawk diy let me
show you how to use the simple key
programmer to make yourself a new key
fob and save tons of money over the car
dealership you can visit tomsky.com
where you can order this for yourself
let's go take a look at how it's done so
here's the new one we're going to
program
we'll put it in
see it does nothing to start the
engine i get a warning light up here on
the dash says wrong key fob
i push the buttons nothing happens
let's program it the simple key user
guide this instruction manual i'll show
you each of the steps that you need to
know
the first thing we've got to do is
activate our the fob that comes with
your simple key programmer it's pretty
easy press
the lock and panic button we're going to
watch for a little light to turn on
sometimes it can be under here in this
case there's a little blue light that's
going to show up right under here
i don't know if you can see that but
there's a
little blue light that's turned on in
there
so that lets you know it's ready to be
activated
now in order to activate it
you need to enter the activation code
so from your instruction manual find
your vehicle in my case this is 2017
dodge ram
the code's 314.
so
to enter the code we're going to
use the lock button so that's the first
digit and the second digit is the panic
button the third digit is the unlock
button
so i've got to turn this back on the
light's turned off
so press and hold
blue light's on so i'm going to enter
three
by clicking lock
one
two
three times
then i'm going to press the panic button
once for the number one
and then my code was three one four so i
need to press unlock four times
one
two
three
four
now i'm going to press the lock and
panic buttons together
and the light will blink back the 314
code
three pause and then one blink pause one
two three four blinks
okay so it got the correct code
all right this has been activated and is
now ready to be programmed the key that
comes in the box will require activation
but many of the additional keys and key
fobs that we sell do not require
activation prior to programming you'll
know this because no activation light
will turn on
this is where we take our simple key
programmer
again with the instruction manual we
come over here find we need to turn to
dial position number four
we're going to plug this into the obd2
port there's this
tamper evidence seal once this is
removed and connected to your vehicle
it will only program for this particular
vin
number you can do more than one keys
more than one key with it if you need
just
to order extra keys from tomsky.com
all the doors shut the vehicle is in
park we're going to turn the hazard
lights on
lights are now running
and now we'll start the vehicle with our
working key
[Music]
geological
survey with the engine running we're
gonna take our installer the simple key
programmer and plug it into the obd2
port down here
you'll hear it beep
okay so it gave three quick beeps
that means it's communicated properly
with the vehicle we can turn the engine
off and pull our working key out
and then it's important to follow the
instructions in dial position 4
it tells you to insert the key but don't
turn it on other dial positions
you do something different you actually
turn it to the on position
okay so we're going to take our new key
and insert it into the ignition
now that it's in the ignition we need to
push the button on top of the simple key
programmer
okay we heard three quick beeps
so we can remove the key now
and we push the button again
[Music]
okay so chimed um that tells us that the
pairing process has been completed
so with that
we're gonna unplug our programmer
turn the hazard lights off
and find out if it works
here we go
[Music]
and starts starts the vehicle just like
that pretty easy to do
you got to be sure you follow the
instructions carefully
we do provide an 800 number in the
frequently asked questions it answers a
lot of the common issues you can run
into or there's a phone number you can
call to get support and customer service
if you run into issues so
all right this guy's starting the
vehicle now
we're going to check our
old key make sure that starts the
vehicle as well
download the var
okay that one works
now let's check our lock buttons
here's the old key
locks unlocks here's the new key
locks
unlocks let's check the panic
and the old one
okay
you got yourself a new key you've saved
a bunch of money pretty easy to do
now don't forget to take the emergency
keyblade to a locksmith car dealership
or hardware store to get it cut to match
your existing key
this will get you into your vehicle if
your car battery dies
to help protect against lost keys we
sell this tile key finder it hooks onto
your keychain and simply pairs with your
smartphone so you always know where your
keys are at
all right so there you have it you saw
just how easy it is to make a new fob
for your dodge go visit tomsky.com and
place an order today i also appreciate
it if you like the video subscribe leave
a comment let everyone know how it works
for you and especially how much money
you're saving over the car dealership to
get one of these made for your vehicle
thanks and have a great day